o total de bovinos e hoje vou ensinar
como fazer umas a epa
vocês perderam bastante para fazer uma
já tinha feito mas esperava cinco balas
é um crime mais complicada e temos de
fazer uma maior e mais simples a cair
conversando com outra claro né
ainda nos comentários acho bacana
tamanho é quase real
uma coisa que eu gosto bastante é ótica
mexe pra cima e pra baixo
isso é bom porque assim você tem alguma
coisa de dez metros querem tentar fazer
o primeiro disparo e vocês vêem onde a
criança eu tô aí vocês vão equipar ótica
querem acertar um objeto disparam e que
vai mais pra baixo até então vocês um
inteiro baixa procura responder os itens
bateu o tiro e depois quando vocês
pararem o próximo tiro olharem pela
ótica eu voltar eu espero que vocês
tenham compreendido
claro que você tem que usar óculos de
proteção estão aqui mas agora acredito
que porque porque estamos aqui com os
elásticos presos aqui à frente de látex
romperem
esta partida vai ter nada para vossa
cara
neste caso nem corromper os dois ao
mesmo tempo que é muito improvável mas
mesmo assim tem que usar sempre proteção
a quem só vamos forçar softbol qualquer
um desses esporte é isso então vamos
agora mais uns testes pois o tutorial
passo passa fora e vou ter que gravar
agora voz o aluno cadeirante e tentei
fazer isso ontem anteontem só que só
teve tempo à noite porque eu ando com
muita coisa na escola e à noite acontece
é que todo mundo lembrou agora de lançar
fogo de artifício então fica sem um
bumbum e eu não consigo fazer nada para
impedir isso então hoje a gravar mas
tendo mesmo conceito
então vocês vão precisar de folhas com
tamanho a3 vocês não tiverem não tem
problema é só juntar em duas folhas a4 e
vão ter uma folha com tamanho a3
vou fazer primeiro uma rifa que vou usar
depois para fazer o tubo e do caribe
agora vou juntar duas folhas a 3
se você tiver a 4 tem que fazer isso
para quatro folhas com o tamanho a4
estou sacola pva mas se vocês não
tiverem podem usar cola botão ou então
aquela escolas líquido escolar que po
colou hu-3 marketing na qual os cara tem
que ir várias folhas a volta do rei foi
com muito cuidado
esta parte inicial é mais difícil mas
quando derem a primeira volta já é muito
mais fácil com cuidado mas é quase
impossível fazer o tubo perfeito então é
só vocês bater um pouco na mesa que já
vai alinhar tudo ok
e para finalizar tem por mais novinho
cola mais ou menos um centímetro da
margem e depois do deslize o tubo se
encontra a mesa e isso vai espalhar a
cola e vai deixar aquela água muito bem
falado um estado fazer três turbinas
usando folhas a4 e estou usar a mesma
roupa da casa para fazer o orçamento do
tubo aprender através com cola eu às
vezes usava e da cola mas não fica tão
bonita com cola fica assim mais
prefeitinho não dá pra perceber muito
bem o que é feito com um chapéu cinzento
vejam que o marca tube com 500 e fiz uma
marca aos 5 centro
vou cortar sua esposa desenhos com cinco
centímetros
vou por agora cola na marcação dos cinco
centímetros até a parte inicial do tubo
e vou colar no tucano
mas vejam que o cano vocês tem que
encostar na marca dos 5 centímetros
depois tem que rolar os outros desenhos
em módulos cada em que cada 25 você
expõe vai sempre utilizando o argumento
para trás fazendo assim empunhadura da
arma tem que cortar sete centímetros de
uma folha quanto amanhã 3 para fazer uma
rifa ligeiramente mais pequena que vai
servir para fazer obtido cortem esse
triângulo e podem usar cola ou então
fita cola e tinta cola porque nesta
quarta e porque vai diminuir o tributo
até aí sim ela é classificado então
ajuda bastante na redução do tributo
vou dobrar agora em um encaixar nos
primeiros dois tubos
eu tenho que estar aqui no pará também
dobrada a impunidade então tem que
ajustar até que chegou à partida têm que
deixar dois tempos de fora e na parte de
baixo não tem que sair nada pra fora
cortem uma impressão de 45 graus espero
ajudar depois de tirar o pistão
agora vou fazer é colônia da arma usar
duas rifas de tamanho a3 e uma rifa
tamanho a4
o processo é bastante simples é só vocês
verem modulando a 5 em penedo a
empreendedora com o que vocês quiserem
fazer cair lá na internet vai exalar -
vocês gostam mais e tentam fazer algo
por cima pra vocês podem usar só duas
rifas
eu vou usar mais uma sobre uma questão
de design acho que é bem bonita popular
por bastante colo importante aqui é uma
coisa quando vocês forem por essa tarefa
se vocês quiserem deixar aquela pequena
distância entre a fifa eo início de
outubro azul aí mais ou menos ali 45 50
anos porque lá vai encaixar o pistão e
se não tiver que o orçamento já não vai
investigar o caso já está feita com
animais ou menos agora na parte da
frente e vamos usar de certo domínio do
ar mais ou menos no lugar no lado e tem
deixado aqui na distância pra vocês
conseguiram puxar o gatilho foi o unión
cola em cima do tubo um outro por cima
da água do mar é pequena e tem que
encaixar dentro de um tubo vazio por
escola ou enrolando a rifa cola para
entrar lá dentro e sim fica fixa para
fixar tem por cola no tubo e na ponta do
lixo
ela permite que eu consiga espalmá-la e
vou usar para contornar empunhadura
porque o empreendedor está muito frágil
e adicionar isto vai aumentar bastante
resistente até
um clã de poder sim porque assim não
tenham pressa parece que eu não espero
que ceku mas é só uma questão de visão a
capital eo parma que o parto de se
esperar a edição corta que parece que
vai ter conseguido mas não é e fica à
espera em cada pedacinho
agora para ficar mais bonito e tamanho
fica mais agradável da grave pois a arma
que fica assim mais volumoso
então fica mais confortável novo vocês
adicionarem este quatro tubos
uma coisa que vai aumentar bastante
resistência do cano vocês adicionarem
cinco patrocínios de pouquinho de picolé
5 tem gente fica lá e vejam que eles têm
que ficar do lado dele mesmo no início é
dodô cana é muito importante porque o
pistão bateu com muita força e batendo
nos pontos de picolé no cano papel
assim a força vai ser dividida pura por
mais paradoxal que ela seja os cinco
pontinhos e pelo cano assim não vai
entregar o carro tão facilmente
vou fazer a ótica e fiz duas óticas seja
você a fazer duas óticas aqui esta que
eu vou ensinar agora se você é um cara
do pequenina o tamanho da arma então de
um crime ou fazer outra mas o princípio
é o mesmo vocês fazem um tubo só tem que
ser maior
olha só o tamanho garante que eu
gostaria de mais ou menos 1 cento entre
maio que eu vou colar a maioria dos
pilotos de picolé
só que só com cola que eu to assim não
fica segura aí fica assim manhã a abanar
então eu vou usar uma rifa palmada é a
mesma que usa a empreendedora e vou
pular por cima modular se aproximar de
mim
enquanto tiver mais ou menos bom
é só pôr bastante escola principalmente
na parte do processo em papel ou em por
cima e segura o tempo necessário até que
o ferry final só terá o chefe pronto
assim comentou cada existência de uma
rifa e tem que dobrar em um assim pra
cima vai permitir que ótica michel que
ele estaria fazendo o possível para
mudar a ótica é cortar estas faixas aqui
e acho que do largura tinha cinco
centímetros 45 anos mas realmente não
lembro a voz eo rosto não é que eu
queira isso é não foi a 3
agora é só aprender aqui
eu vou porque minha mãe foi uma gota de
escola em cada lado de craques aqui
e para finalizar só falta mesmo fazer o
que estão a usar uma rifa naquelas com o
olhar 3 do braille e é o tecido branco
mais ou menos e quatro centros se
entende alguns incidentes não os quatro
tempos assim mas somente até podem
cortar outros docinhos é igual àquela
parte do brasil até o tamanho é uma
coisa que vai aumentar bastante
resistente e darão um elástico e foi um
cola nesse ponto assim mas tenham
cuidado para a cola não ir em cima do
elástico porque se for vai estragar o
rei então cuidado com isso foi um cola
no outro lado e colo enquanto assim a
questão linear
é muito importante que vocês usem fita
cai bastante fita nesta parte porque com
o impacto a cola pode esconder se mas a
fita não a fita pode mudar ligeiramente
posição mas continua lá que eu tô seguro
cai nesta parte tem que ser mesmo muita
fita já está mais ou menos mais com o
que ele acha que não chega tem que
acrescentar mais elástica com elásticos
de cada lado e desta maneira o flamengo
vai depender dos votos elástico só que
vocês tiverem lá você tem que ver quanto
é que eles mais ou menos para chegar à
parte da frente da gestão tem que pôr os
ovos proteção porque os elásticos podem
aguentar o cofre momento a caixa só que
eu vou juntar agora relaxei e vou
aprender com fio que falta uma pequena
parte que é extremamente importante é
quando eu ponho super cola por forçar
algumas partes estratégicas que são
fundamentais para a arma ao funcionário
sair fizeram até que quiserem ver onde é
que devem pôr cola eu vou deixar um link
na descrição de um outro vídeo que o fiz
vocês vão lá para o final e vão
compreender o que vocês têm que fazer ok
então e só peço desculpa mas só vai
conseguir não sei o que aconteceu é que
eu lembro ter feito essa coisa eu não
quero ir pra gravar o que acontece é
muito chato ou então sai só queremos o
fim está no estado e agora eu fiquei em
casa pensava o que aconteceria se está a
aguentar-se então eu vou estar usando
óculos de proteção e pois alguns tirar
duas conclusões
o que é que vocês podem ver o relativo
disparados por vossa cara aquele
salientam os exemplo alguns e isso vocês
quiserem e acho que até é melhor podem
usar o milho vai ser só para enfeitar o
tapete para banho assim também ok então
isso é importante e vai até a próxima
tal e